hey
well good evening everyone i'm glad you
all made it tonight here grandma's also
i'm already about the grandmaster in
residence at san lucious club
i've been here since last
since
not this monday i'm past monday august
9th i'll be here until through
august 31st
and tonight we're going to have the
grand master choice
so they they left it to me so i chose
something a little bit exciting
difficult as well but quite exciting i
hope you guys are going to have fun with
it
um
the content of today's class is talking
about this the opening that is quiet uh
in my opinion in my opinion interesting
and and exciting
and this is this opening do you know
what the name of this opening is
although
down there just down here you can see it
says
siciliante manov
so knight c3 queen c7 bishop e3
white prepares the move uh
white prepares the move after h6
so
this movement should be three usually
is played
where's my
uh no i have a mouse okay
so
this idea usually is to what for white
to essay queen d2 f3 and castle long and
g4 known as do you know the name of it
who knows the name of this attack
what's that
english in general yes adam's just
played but yep english attack
but here the new trend is that they play
the smooth queen to f3 became very
trendy so the idea is that i want to
play the move g4 anyways
but instead
but i cannot read the chat but
at all
it's uh behind other windows
if you click on it it should come up
there it is
do you see it
yeah
somebody says is that the last thing i'm
excited ben is that what it is
uh don't look too far back
it's uh
okay that goes back quite a bit
it won't be relevant
now i'm not going
far back just
ashamed getting his mangoes okay good
who said that is that tracy okay good
yeah the mango is in place the glass is
rolling okay
okay so uh
then uh what's the idea behind queen f3
i want to talk about that so in the law
of these ideas they go b5 and queen
bishop b7 so i want to do my long castle
i keep the move g4 on uh on tap but but
also i had the idea of queen to g3 which
leads to trade the queens and after they
move f3 g4
this structure with the pawn on d7 is
quite weak for black which and usually
it's very ironic for me because when i
learned this they were saying that in
game is very good for black
but nowadays we know it's not that easy
there is no user submitted that is
tomorrow and actually tomorrow is the
analyzer games and i'm going to cover
all my games at the us open where i
qualified for the u.s championship i
tried for first and i qualified to the
us championship so we don't have uh
viewers games this week
no viewers games this week
so
uh queen f3 i keep the move g4 i want to
cast along anyways and i want to play
queen g3 trading queens and then play f3
g4
and the famous game if you google there
is a blitz game between nepalnyochi and
uh
and do both and easy napoli actually won
that game showing that this endgame is
quite quite dangerous i have to talk
like two sessions why that endgame is
good for black just take it as grand
take take my word for it that that end
game with queen g3 takes hg with f3 g4
this uh trade queen trade and then f3 g4
with other queens on the board it's
quite good for white
which i said i was it's ironic because
when i when i was learning chess and was
new to this opening they were saying oh
this end game is quite good for black
and they were they were bringing the end
game from um
um
sultan khan who used to play the english
championships and he had many wins in it
with black pieces
but in times of sultan khan people
didn't know that you have to go f3 g4
to reinforce the pawn on e4 and that
makes a huge difference
so now we know
time has changed that was 1920s 30s so
time has changed
so
knight e5 following the theory this is a
game over actually between vege and uh
on the host and this is when i started
studying this opening because
it's been a long time since i've i've
been studying uh since i had studied
actually
since i studied uh
i had studied the
sicilian and when i when i came across
this
i was like this is interesting i have
not studied the system i i stopped
playing the timeout
because i didn't like english attack and
not that because it's too dangerous just
i had to memorize a lot and
i said i thought maybe wait a second
maybe maybe it's not the bad it's it's
not that bad that i quit playing time on
off because it seems to be dangerous so
when i saw this game first in 2015
it was a little bit uncomfortable for me
going back to sicilian but the engines
got better the more i worked on chest i
realized that
this opening is actually pretty playable
for black
so queen g3 h5 now you would say elisha
what's going on here black is not
developing
keep playing with the same pieces again
and uh
what's he doing so first thing is that
he wants to kick up kick my queen
and uh making a space for his pieces
basically and in case of f4 he's ready
to face it with knight two g4 so
long castle h4 queen here and b5
now my queen is bad in actually what
what is a heading what matt you know i
always talk about it right is the head
in what
development right
so what goes f4 here capture capture so
it's a very funny situation because
black has a very good
pawn structure
and these pawns are really restricting
wise pieces
on the other hand
on the other hand
what is anyways ahead in development so
y plays f5
bishop b7
rook hitch f1
we're developing what both players are
developing e5 knight b3
and uh
black played the move queen c7 makes a
lot of sense right because i have to
cover this square right
the pawn on e5
so
someone says i love the queen sack i'm
gonna mention no
keros but uh okay
so
and here i play them with king b1
okay the first critical moment
so
i'm going to ask everyone give everyone
some time if you were black
and i'm going to flip the board for you
to look at it what would you have done
um
like to move here
okay we have the move knight f6 in the
house somebody says knight f6 what else
ben you think if i eat
mango club with band mangoes
on the side or no
i mean if you ask
unlimited mango okay
that works
should add it to my next contract then
roxy we have a roxy somebody's saying
bishop before we have
bishop a3 uh
takes on b5 result c8
uh knight f6 okay we have three moves
bishop before knight f6 and rook seed i
still don't use engine i'm going to use
at some point but not yet
so
so bishop before guys there's knight d5
you kind of have to think twice when you
play that move
rook see it you want to stop the move
knight d5 okay that makes a lot of sense
yes
yeah
yep
and uh
okay i'm gonna give it two more minutes
to people to just think a little bit
more
after bishop b4 yes
maybe
knight e7 no there's f6 not e7 is
definitely wrong
and bishop c52 there's not c5 everything
bishop a3 now there's bishop g5
that doesn't work
anything else guys i'm looking at the
chat i have some moves here people are
giving me some moves here in the
audience and anything else
another movie except rook c8 bishop b4
or knight f6
yeah guys you see the problem of this
opening is if you don't know the opening
exactly
you have to you have to have three
things either are very good at
calculation you don't know your opening
or both
or then you're going to have problem
playing this as black
so a lot of people are saying rook c8
including some of my friend our friends
here they said that i'll give them
uh now it was played in the game but
it's a losing move it loses by force
rook c it loses by force
the the right one is knight f6
sorry oh oh
i don't want to show the point
so i'm going to show you the first move
i first play f6
knight f6
now what happens guys
then what happens
good mango man
you want some
no good
ben is too professional for me
always
different level
yeah
what move
uh-huh
b6 yes
it's a very strong move
knight eighth knight there
knight a5 i cannot take on b6 because
the the pawn on d7 is hanging queen is
seven six and then
foreign
yes this is similar to magnus vs judy
pogo magnus lost in 19 moves during the
candidates outside in the park playing
against judy polgar he lost the same
theme basically
not trade capture on
b7 it's knight b7
and
rp8
there's one more move here
yeah there's this move okay
95
and if i take here
it's what
it's fantastic
it's insane
then okay
say i go
okay is it chat related about this
hey welcome so say i go to queen takes
g2
i just removed the rook and made right
anything is made now
if i go say
if i go here what happens
rookie six
no i'm thinking d7
rook d4 is mate yeah i wonder if there
is a there was one way
so if he goes queen d7
yeah i moved
there was one way that i have a second
mate two which is
the coolest mate is what i'm trying to
remember there's another cool mate that
if he goes queen c3 i can't take on c3
of course i can't take on c3 and win but
there's this cool mate i just want to
show the concept here
check
capture and then checkmate this is very
cool too
another cool mates too so many cool
mates
yeah it's very cool so
let's go back
uh
he played rook txb7 then what do we do
it's very beautiful yes then i go queen
c3 of course go for the mate
there cannot go back he goes queen c6
and that was the win
give everyone two minutes
um
um
yeah he went here and walked into a maze
but oh sorry
it's amazing yeah but yeah if he takes
after this check
capture quintex c6 and that's over so
when i first saw this i was like wow
what what's it like but i'm gonna run
engine a little bit for you guys
and you will see
you will see this
okay this position
um
what is where is the
analysis
you guys have icloud analysis so new oh
you're sick
is it still uh control three is that
still the magic combo
what's control three
i think it's control three
it's deep phrase i mean it's useless
we we're better off not to just even do
it yeah no no we don't need this
there's a sound bite for the ages
what's that
a glowing review
a long review for uh not here
yeah starfish 11 not great but but
better than nothing this because this
position has been analyzed quite a bit
so yeah this is this rook see it but
here
knight f6 is pretty good and i know i
think malachotko played this position
let me see if my my memory still works
and he had a good position he won this
game
yeah there we go
ben simon i have a good memory did you
know that
there's someone after that in him too so
yeah we looked at this and i realized oh
wait a second it's not that bad although
the wind is very crushing this game is
really crushing
but after this move 95 it was actually
it wasn't winning it's not 95 and
everything so you also have a pawn
sacrifice i've i've spent quite some
time
studying this position
but back at the time when i said back at
the time in 2019 before kovis so this is
my pre-code analysis
so knight f6 and then is good so then i
say okay then it's playable but how come
nvls keep winning in this
so we look at mvl
we show again what was there and then
then we should hold the main line that
is the
what everybody's looking at so okay now
let me close this one
now let's get to mvl versus anand
by the way um
in my book that is available here that i
co-authored with woman's grandmaster
sabine fosho
we we have both these games of anand and
hare krishna that they lost in
that
they lost to mvl
both games are featured there are
certain positions in them that that
makes it very interesting so
more thorough explanations are in the
book
so
all right so let's play
anything
black's not better after knight f6 but
enveloped with white
the name of the book is sherlock's
method
queen of three
knight f6
so this time didn't go for 95 it's
playable both will it will con
it will uh
it will transpose it will transpose from
one to another so knight f6 there
95 point g3 and b5 so letting the move
f4 being played and uh
the f4 is the main line here the move
also a3 was being played in this game
though so angel used to play some of a3
and this is kind of very odd because in
the first place you would think what
about bishop a3 okay that doesn't work
because of queen g7
but what if i just don't do anything
let's say i play bishop b7
what's the idea behind white's play it
seems that black is playing rook c8 d5
sims is very odd the way black white
played unless there is a plan what is
wise plan here
and my plan is simple i'm going to
finish the mangoes before the end of the
class
knight a2 no no no
f3
f3
and then try to play the queen f2 g4
f3 he might go b4
rook see it before his attack is coming
up very fast right
when you make it so
in sicilian defense when you make a move
like a3 which is weakening you are
playing on the side that your king is
then
and it is played by player at the level
of mvl then you would think there is
something concrete and
thorough there
so
when you when you are setting a theory
and you see wait a second what does a3
do
weakens the structure gives bishop takes
a3 as as a motive to to to white
so when that move is being played
something really concrete and sharp
follows
otherwise they don't play these kind of
moves
besides the pawn on e4 is under attack
where our friend so what's your name sir
back there
oh alex alex
you you mentioned something no oh no was
you were mentioning sorry you were
machine sorry alex you mentioned about
adams i think yeah i'm sorry just
the light doesn't let me see everyone
correctly sorry um
so
f3 was mentioned by you what's your name
sorry josh josh so matt and sergey
what's your name
yes you
mark okay
hey tracy
so
um
so in this position
uh yeah so in this position e4 is under
attack and if you go f3 rook c f d5 is
coming f4 knight c4 it's this falling
for why do i need to move a3 because
before i would like to go bishop knight
a4 but now before i have to trade it
really doesn't stop anything
so what follows is right sack the bishop
yes somebody said it sack the bishop
bishop b5
very typical sacrifice
uh a3 is is waiting off to play bishop
b7 because if i go
bishop b5 now
cap
[Music]
capture capture
no sorry there's no that piece we should
be sick so sorry there is no bishop b6
because when the bishop is on b7 there
is a bishop b6 and now there is no
bishop b6 now he was about to play
bishop a6 and now i don't really have a
threat here what if i played bishop
about f4 there instead we saw what
bishop takes b5 so a3
okay here so yeah in this line knight d
yep and then queen b8 bishop f4
well first of all i have knight h5 to
begin with
there's also d6 we go take take
and queen g793 check
g3 bishop b8 knight h1 knight c7 check
that's fair enough
okay d6
knight d3 check
no this looks good this looks very good
so let me see
anything from the chat guys
and what is white yes
maybe i shouldn't go there and then
where do i go i have nowhere else to go
well since we don't have time and i have
two more games to show you let me let me
use the ng no no no let's use the engine
i i don't like you to use the engine but
you know
so capture capture
bishop f4
it says this is that position
wow
okay no was it 90s what's what's that i
mean
wow it's been played quite a bit
actually let me just give you some space
here so you can see the board can you
see the board
okay knight d6 capture
queen g7 oh wow this is this is losing
his position why this is losing
rook f8 oh my god
and then if i capture
just just like that okay it wasn't that
obvious to me oh wait a second we're
still up a piece what am i oh my god
what am i talking about i'd even count
the pieces of course
that was why i said 93 in the first
place oh my god my brain is fried i need
more mango i'm sure i need more mango
oh my god my brain is fried yes the two
bishops are too strong we should be five
that bishop sits on e5 very strong
bishop comes to c4
because there are too many lines open to
our wise king and it's not enough the
night and
all of that so
i i tied for first somebody's asking if
i um
fight brain attack now that would be
fried liver attack but my liver is my
liver is not doing actually that great
because of the i have i have gilbert
syndrome but that's okay
it's it's under control so
uh
uh no it's actually perfectly fine it's
functioning just fine
so um
uh
yes bishop a6
and it makes sense because of that yet
so but rook f8 naruto is not not good
oh wow
oh if i go here
wow one tempo makes a huge difference
wow okay i learned something guys
i'll learn something anyways
i'm glad you have fun you're seeing so
here knight d3 yeah so this is not
working so anyways bishop b5 here is an
option apparently played by morozevich
kogan
but
jimenez
cora fidel
okay so it's a common move too
anyways i i told you i i only studies
for my students i don't play this with
either color
i don't enter this position so i'm not
that deep about this this position but
it's it's considered oh i look at this
these two i play some correspondence
games these two are legends in
correspondence just
i've seen this game of this guy but this
guy the olivier is like a very strong
correspondence player and corresponds
players nowadays is that they run engine
for days and play against each other so
basically whoever has
more time and more engine power huh
so um if it's a draw that means there's
nothing anyways
thanks for mentioning the bishop e5
earlier i thought it's it's it's a bad
move but it's actually playable move so
anyways
mvl goes for the for the for the capture
anyways later on
but ana knows what he's doing and he
played stay cool and played and moved
rook to c8
that's his novelty oh let me just close
this again we don't want all the info
here
that was his novelty and uh i don't
think it's rattled mvl because and we'll
just simply drop the bishop back here
the move bishop e2 i think he tried it
later on
against the
against harder christian which we see in
the next game so bishop a4
knight x e4
knight x e4 bishop takes e4 bishop f4
so that's the idea of placing the bishop
here why because there's no more to move
d6 because because the pawn is pinned
and also the bishop correctly defend the
defend the c2 pawn as well
that's what it enables the move bishop
f4 otherwise he had to do something else
because c2 would be hanging
so bishop f4 and queen c4
uh
there's also one more thing just to
mention here
about bishop e2 we'll get there let me
see if there are questions in the chat
yes now before somebody asked i have to
mention now a b5 doesn't work because
now the bishop is on b7 if i go queen b
there's a bishop b6 if i go ab5
now it's losing because there's bishop
b6 then when the bishop was on stage we
didn't even have that option then we had
to go with bishop f4
so bishop b5 rook c8 bishop a4 capture
capture bishop f4 queen c4 a counter
queen a5 would lead to the same thing
queen c4
bishop takes e5 bishop b3 knight d3 yes
you don't want to you don't want to
enter this one
obviously you should not take stakes
okay now c2 is hanging or c2 is the is
the only way
to protect it
and
f6 bishop d6 king f7
rookie one
bishop g6 all four smooths captured on
f8
capture
queen d6
king g8 now black's king is safe he
finally castled out of out of blood out
of nowhere he finally castled
and now
white has
do i have to play e5 is a threat right
black wants to play e5 and then the
pressure on c2 is mounting right this
this is this pressure on because this
knight is defending so he wants to play
this one so i have to go for preventing
that right
all right
what's that
instead
queen b4
you were saying like you're better
yes there's a problem queen before i'm
not surrounding an engine but i think
there's this problem i go to e5
i'm sorry after capture i go e5 knight
b3 and then i go d5 you cannot take it
so once you go knight c5 i have a5 and
if you don't play at c5 next more i'm
playing d4
and because of the pressure on c2 i
thought i could take on d5 but no no you
cannot it's because of this pawn is
hanging everybody's seeing that mark
you're good
good everybody in the chat matt you're
following
yeah that's that yeah that's uh the e5
thing so i have to stop that but now as
you said actually queen before is now
one option now i want that end game now
i want that end game
so okay
oops i should did i show the answer or
not maybe not okay why should black do
not now this is critical for black i'm
going to give everyone like a couple of
minutes to think a little bit
um
rook c6 knight x
um
look c4 there is b3 that's the problem
that is right
you'll also have to recognize white has
some thread like f5 at some point too
sacking the pawn and putting the rook on
e7
this is a hard one
this is a hard one
all right
the right move is queen c4
because i'm i'm eyeballing this move
king b1
then the e5 takes takes and uh
surprisingly i don't have a good good
capture
so if if queen takes on e5
then i have a k8
and then capture rook f1 yeah i want to
just show everyone this
and then it will have fun follows
and if rookie five i think it's just
mate right
that's just me it's okay
so cannot do that so he must play the
move queen takes d7 bishop f7
not and then it's it and then he gets he
gets the fight he was looking for
he beat the black skin we gave up two
pounds but we got to black's king we got
very active honestly i don't want to be
white in this position
it's very complicated but
i'm not claiming to have fun playing
this with either color because the kings
are very weak and playing with the weak
king unless i know what i'm doing and i
believe
mvl knew what he's doing and probably
online forgot his his analysis
i think
playing this probably
maxim knew that because entering his
position without having
preparation it's madness i mean your
king is walking to the center
i'm not sure if king d1 is a move
actually i don't think it's a move
but anyways because there's nothing
which i've checked in
i think it mattered
yeah i think you have some rook move or
something anyways i i can't run and we
can't look let me just look at it
so when people say oh wow he had a
defense he missed it he forgot it
because this guy's looking rock d6 yes
of course look d6 how stupid of me not
seeing rook d6 huh
no it's not that easy i mean come on you
give up the move you give up the pawn
then it captures looks is oh come on
preposterous
and then the drawing move rook the 8 98
check 24 check perpetual or rookie 8 26
i mean come on give me a break
so i'm sure this was in in
if someone could look into
maxima schilograph files an analysis
this is sitting there
you cannot play this without having this
uh already
in your files
it's madness to enter this without
without having having that in mind and
i'm sure it was announced files too he
just forgot during the game
yeah very deep line
so anand made a mistake played rook f8
rookie three this is a very strong move
i'm gonna let the engine run because
this is quite difficult and i want to
show the next one against hare krishna
which is very interesting rookie three
then envious play is very you see anand
remembered his idea but now it's too
late because now queen function has
queen king b2
and the thing is why he can't play b3
now because the rook on e3
the rook on e3 controls the square
so in the previous line black had to
move point c3 whereas in this one he
doesn't have that so he's not solid
queen goes back to c7 and now the end
game is just bad and then
and then we'll gradually just
just improve his position and i love
this maneuver i love this maneuver a lot
so here's the point i'm going to stop
this just to understand this is a very
beautiful provocative menu where i'm
going to flip the board
this is in our book
with sabina he goes 92
he's threatening to move rook to d6
not to only capture but he's
strengthening the rook d6 attacking the
spawn and after they move d5
he goes back 94.
so he just provokes the pawn so the bass
moves to the pawn and he just becomes
weak and now there's no defense against
the pawn on uh for e6 and then after
this it's gone this is a beautiful move
i love this move
it's it's so deep so beautiful
so
so uh rook c7 and then envel gradually
just
converts because just he's dominant here
now
and yeah another resigned because yeah
this is over
such a dominant performance but it all
came down to one move
and that's how it goes in the top level
play and it is not that the other person
doesn't know
it's just you
your psychology was
correct your choice of moves your choice
of opening was such that
you catch your opponent
in the right moment
i think both players files would look
exactly the same just online probably
forgot
it's a bit it's a bit saddening right to
think that oh my god chess has been
regressed to just moves
but look they also understand all these
moves
so the beauty of it for me is that these
guys
not only memorize these moves they
understand the nuances they're so
detailed but they can comprehend each
moment of the game
i mean listen to these guys talking with
each other it's so
beautiful to me
because like they're like
academics they know their stuff to the t
and to me is beautiful i don't know
okay
i won't get to show the main line
but i'm going to show the game again
and will hari krishna
this okay we have the same line
this time around
and we'll first play this move
and change his lines a little bit
and then
if i was played by hari krishna
it's a very critical moment in the game
uh ben do we have to finish at 30 or no
we can we go a couple of myself okay all
right
so i'm gonna give everyone three minutes
to think about just white this position
also is given at sherlock's method in
static book
queen bee
excuse me
think a little bit further
think a little bit further
the only hint i can give you guys
i come from iran so we are very much
into proverbs whatever glitters is not
gold
thank you
with someone online just bishop e5 whoa
that's very ballistic bishop e5 i think
i think this can run into bishop takes
a3 and that
looks extremely dangerous oh no no he
has queen here what am i talking about
we should be five
maybe bishop b4
ah it doesn't feel right it should be
four probably yeah we should be four
and then f takes e5 because then it
comes to each like this one maybe i'm
i'll check with the engine
and narrow catch e8
take your time
hare krishna also either forgot queen b3
the problem with queen b3 is
i take take and i play rook take c2
c2 bishop c2 and yeah
we are down upon
but we know the end game is better for
us yes we know the end game is better
for us
so you want to get that end game but you
need to be to do it with a little bit
more tact
and in chess a little bit more text
makes your tactician
someone says pawn g5 i'm sorry i'm not
following
g3
you mean b3
yes b3 is the move
b3 is the move
it's very strong move
i tell you why this makes a huge
difference so before that i want to
discuss this bishop e5 i just want to
make sure that i didn't give some random
move
my first intuition was bishop before but
let me see all right let's just capture
actually [ __ ] before it's not the right
move just capture first
and then just go key king g86 as you can
see didn't see that okay
oops
but okay at least i saw the second best
move which is
somewhat some with advantages
all right
b3 very strong move queen a5
queen h3 very another important move
winning a temple with the rook
forcing this move
b4
queen a4
queen b3 check
so now you got what you wanted but first
he distracted you see that queen h3 was
very important i first
i first deflect the queen on a4
then i deflect the rook to t it is
double deflection basically just it's
not tactical it's more positional double
deflection goes here now before queen a4
and now queen b3 check works because
there's no tick c2 anymore
that was deep
and beautiful yes
uh i'm just curious was this something
this idea of e3
do you think this is something he
prepped at home or found it with the
board
i think it was cooked also it's very
everything he played was very accurate
because when we were putting it in the
book he played almost like a machine
however
a lot of time they don't remember it
they play at the board but when you're
aware of an idea
that makes it much easier i have games
that my analysis ends on move 15 but
because i have spent a lot of time on
the position playing blitz games with my
friend going back and forth discussing
it with someone you know the idea so
kind of the right moves come to you and
then you look in the right direction so
knowing the right directions so
he may not have had it in his files
but he was aware of the idea
right like if you had told me
e3 is good in these types of positions
yeah you see that's the thing and that's
that that's the point he's studying this
position so he was aware of the idea so
and being in vlan is so good at tactics
and i mean it's crazy how crazy how good
these guys are and then they come across
one way or another sometimes they don't
sometimes on a bad day or something on a
good day so that's that's how the
differences are made in that level
and then bishop five knight c5
bishop e7
there capture capture f4 instead this is
dead
and when's the pawn
and that's game over
upper pawn
all right i the next game i was going to
be did that which was the closing which
which is the actual the the trend
we don't have so much time i'm just
going to give a glimpse of it and maybe
in the future we're going to discuss it
a little bit
yeah it's
very it's it's it's very precise
uh uh okay let's
i think i think he went wrong with with
rookie iroki to hear e5 is not correct
that's a good question i forgot to
mention this
now if i was correct
if i was not correct
again queen c4 huh
the same move
the very same move
it's just a transposition it's just i
think it's just a transposition
so he repeated the same line as anand
he probably had his own prep and he
forgot this here area queen c4
b3 and queen c3
well it's not as bad because now
i have this guy sitting here so it's not
as bad it's just somewhat [ __ ]
slightly bad now he's got he's got play
now f4 bishop h5 and
well this is still uncomfortable i think
this is considered not a great line i
think what i analyzed myself and it's in
the book
yes h5 i put h5 with rook h6
i also
happen to look at
yes this is this is my line and this is
what i looked at
and b3 we just we're about to take here
if he takes then then you take with the
king and you run away like this and then
this is going to be very solid with the
king on g this h5 and the king runs or
this h5 versions of f6 that's what i
looked at
you want more thorough analysis you can
look in the book if not you can email me
after you read the book
yeah anyways uh
just a quick glimpse of it
uh okay everybody's leaving just a quick
thing
this is okay this was the position this
is where
we are and now it is this is where the
theory is bishop g g1 or bishop d2 and
then there's h5 for the most part if you
let the engine run it's a zero zero but
it's quite
it's quite
sharp
results used to be good for white but
it's gradually black is the more people
are playing it the more the theory
advances and people memorize more lines
and getting to know what needs to be
played at certain points especially with
the game which i don't get to show you
between
nakamura and p-shot or i don't know
p-i-c-h-o-t it's a it's an argentinian
name i don't know if it's pisco or pirot
i don't know
but excuse me for my lack of knowledge
of any any sort of
spanish or argentinean last names
um we know that black's results is
getting better and better
if i don't come across something
completely different from this one i
might pick up from this point onward
next tuesday otherwise we'll look at
something else
i hope you guys enjoyed
and had fun
when simon didn't have any fun look at
his face completely like uh
just
shut up and be done okay
and i'm going to do that now
of course take it easy everyone have a
good one and thanks for joining
[Music]
you